most of the hypotheses that Kepler  developed to explain physical forces  were later rejected as inconsistent to  Newtonian theory or we have no error so  the part that seems a little strange to  me is when they talk about inconsistent  to you don't say that you're  inconsistent to something you say that  you're inconsistent with inconsistent  with something study a is not  inconsistent to study be you would say  study a is inconsistent with study be so  this should be inconsistent with and if  i were to rewrite this i would write  this as most of the hypotheses that  kepler developed to explain physical  forces were later rejected as being as  being inconsistent with Newtonian theory  that sounds a lot better inconsistent  with so the error is in d